I'm Tim Frye the director of the Herman
Institute the Herman Institute has been
in existence since 1946 and we've had
many interesting speakers over the years
but I think this is the first time we've
had the heavyweight champion of the
world graced our stage it's my great
pleasure to introduce Vitaly Klitschko
who has not only been very successful in
sport many of you may not know but he
also has a PhD in in sports science and
you can refer to him as dr. Klitschko
therefore and as successful as he has
been in sports and in academia he is now
as many of you know turned his attention
to politics and since 2006 he's been a
member of the Kiev City Council in 2008
he became a member of the opinion
delegation to the Congress of the
Council of Europe and in April 2010 he
became a leader of a party the Ukrainian
Democratic Alliance for reforms with
what I think is one of the best and
short names Aadhaar which i think fits
fits Vitaly Klitchko perfectly he the
title of his talk will be what future is
there for Ukraine he will speak for
about 25 minutes and then we'll open up
the floor for questions so I hope you'll
all join me in welcoming Vitaly
Klitschko
mm ladies and gentlemen you got some
dear friends I would like to Saints
Harmon Institute and his director
Timothy Frey also marker and rich chick
and ambassador
Valerie Kaczynski for the chance to be
today here to have a chance to talk
about your brain to explain powerful
sedation in green tea to tell about our
party new political movement our party
and after that after the speech I hope
we have a chance to the best one we have
a discussion and we have a question and
I hope for my answer will be full I want
to say thank you Ron I'm sorry for my
English is not perfect but I give my
best
with our new political party in Ukraine
we're very young we just 1/2 years old
but today we're number 4 big part in
Ukraine and we have pretty good support
in Ukraine in if election will be
tomorrow our party will be in Parliament
and we very appreciate for everybody who
hope we can change the rules in Ukraine
and we give the best to do that
what do is good our stand for Ukraine
because we are proud to be Ukrainian
Democratic because why democratic values
is the best value and the world has not
created a better political system that
system then democracy aliens because we
try to unite all the cranium you just
all together we can we can make changes
in Ukraine reform because our alliance
put at the center of activities Ukraine
people and citizen who want to live in
better country and on the real reform
for the people have a chance to change
Ukraine my speech today I would like to
focus your attention and three important
topics first I would like to tell you a
little about myself and about their
goals and
of objectives of our party Buddha second
I would like to tell you about some of
the problems issues facing in Ukraine
today and who the country against system
be standing first I would like to tell
you about my and hood our vision for
fixing the situation Ukraine and some of
the first steps we believe needs to take
Ukraine put back in democratic path
about us last month Ukraine celebrate 20
years in dependency I remember this time
very well 20 years ago I was young man I
was 20
we everybody work for independent
Ukraine everybody
we hope good future for our country we
working for democracy we have a dream to
build new democracy independent country
but if only 20 years later the situation
is much different
let me tell you numbers because the
numbers don't have emotions 63 percent
of Ukrainian
minds believe the country developed the
wrong direction more than 50% of
Ukrainian don't believe any political
party any politician every Ukraine's
want to look in the future with
confidence but we can't don't have
normal living standards do Ukrainian
people who have jobs is not confirmed
there we kept them more than 20%
population looking for employment
opportunities outside of Ukraine
many people believe Ukraine is stealing
back if its commitment to democratic
values everyone is worried about which
way we go and which way going country
and many people have a question some say
we are returning to autocracy many of
yours I don't know
follow sport career of brothers
Klitschko and just few weeks two weeks
ago three weeks ago many of us a chance
to see the fight in Poland I want to say
thank you for sport sport hell give me
opportunities to travel around the world
to meet new people to understand
mentality of Nations to meet many
different people many religions many
cultural and a couple of weeks ago I
fought in defend my wall title in Poland
last time I wasn't Poland beginner 90s
we have actually began nineties almost
the same starting position Ukraine
Poland Czech Republic Hungary today this
country's already members of European
Union and I see how is big different
today between Ukraine and Poland and I
give me question why why we miss the
time wise this life standards in this
countries with who we starting to build
independent countries democratic
countries so big and so different
we speak about huge potential what heavy
brain in 20 years and we continue to
talk to talk about potential in Ukraine
and today we believe we need to realize
potential what we have what we propose
Ukraine needs reform to change the
country unfriendly from the government
all we get is top-down reform the
reforms are more for the power not for
the people it's a great example the
party of power the beginning reform in
Ukraine
everybody understand Ukraine need reform
but reform for himself not for the
people if politician if if politician
don't have a few what people need don't
if politicians lose the contact to the
people they don't have a future
a good example today gown just year ago
the government's beginning with the
reform tax reform immediately the next
days hundreds of thousand people gone to
street and protest
against this reform because reform
doesn't support the interest of small
and middle business exactly the same
example about about pension reform the
government decide we have to make
exactly the same age pension age like in
Europe we want to live with your
European numbers but they forget about
life standards in Europe in life
standards in Ukraine and not everyone
can reach new pension age and understand
what has been pension reform to feel bad
because
in Ukraine people live much shorter than
people in Europe
it's everything depend of live standards
we believe that the main goal of
politicals is not here and under to hear
and understand the people people his
government have lose the trust of today
of many people in Ukraine
what kind of reform what we need in
Ukraine immediately to change last
couple of days the news from a grain was
headline every way in the world and that
way feels very important point
stop persecution of the opposition and
start a serious dialogue between
government and opposition it's call on
the immediately realize of Timoshenko
Lutz Anka and others Leader of
Opposition the church again then the
political and have nothing to do with
the rule of law second stop suppression
of free speech and breaking free
meetings choice who defend their rights
to oppose the tax or pension system
should not be detained for expression
their opinions or gathering in front of
public
buildings the next point adopt the
election law for next year 2012 which
fair rules that clearly reflect the will
and wishes of waters including
candidates from open political party
lists involving youth and women in
political life will help us modernized
our society women's make up 63%
Ukrainians what in population but the
majority in power the man our party in
City Council and 30% woman and we very
happy with that
and we want more woman in our party the
next point
Ukraine need reforms we need to move
from closet oligarch economy which
monopolized to economy is equal import
opportunities allowing small and medium
business to make money creating
opportunities for the young people will
stop the immigration to Europe foreign
investors will return to our country to
Ukraine implementing and the next point
implementing can consist policy of
European integration it's a guarantee of
Ukraine democratic development will
return trust to government and politics
Herrera European integration has two
components democracy and economic they
go hand-in-hand
one cannot flowering without the others
we talk I hope I explained it bit about
our party about Qatar and the bald
situation in Ukraine I hope in
discussion we have to open much more men
equations last 20 years we talk about
potential what we have in Ukraine 20
years celebration 20 years go so fast
like one minute
I don't want in 20 years the next 20
years will be going so fast like last
one and I don't want to tell about time
of missed opportunities in 20 years and
that why together with people who have
exactly the same vision with people who
have exactly the same values the people
who change our vision will we see
Ukraine as democratic country with huge
potential and we don't want to wait next
20 years we know we can change make a
change in Ukraine very fast for that we
need political will and we're ready for
that we invest our time energy and
vision and know we can do with that
thank you very much for your time it's
Rubio I hope it will be much easier and
much more interesting to starting to
talk because in discussion we can open
many questions much better and dialogue
between the people is always good thank
you very much
thank you very much for that wonderful
speech Yuri Shevchuk will be translating
your questions and mr. Klitschko's
responses if I could ask anyone who
would like to ask a question to go to
the microphone in the back of the room
and we'll take your questions one by one
this is this is what we like to see a
student coming up and asking the first
question we like that very much um thank
you for coming mr. Klitschko my question
is you mentioned in your speech that
it's necessary for Ukraine to move away
from the sort of hidden oligarchic
corrupt economy and how how concretely
can Ukraine do that what concrete steps
for economic reforms
thank you and that who should forget
what the Russians back who she Padilla
caught is watches the padania proper
English is better i I'm sorry for
mistakes if I need if I need support of
translator sorry if you tossin use
language every day you lose language and
that wise I travel around around the
world pretty long time was outside of
the country then why is my english not
not perfect and that why I'm sorry for
that
first of all Ukraine have great
opportunities it's very painful to to
read Ukrainian smash craft country in
the world and its biggest reason why
Ukraine doesn't developed in don't make
a step to European integration and waste
problem problem is many investors ready
to come into Ukraine to develop business
but in Ukraine we have business doesn't
have doesn't enjoy equal opportunities
its business doesn't have equal
opportunities in Ukraine its it people
in politics why it's unusual situation
sportsmen go to politics
many of people ask me why you do that I
use portsmen you can enjoy the time
because I travel around the world I see
how develop the country in in Europe in
I I see live standards in United States
live standards in Europe and if we come
back to Ukraine we do equation very
simple things what work around the world
modern countries doesn't work in Ukraine
where is the reason the answer is simple
the people in government the people who
decide which way we go they announced
right things we go to Europe is European
value is priority for us but they is not
interesting to change situation because
politic for them simple business they
make big money they come to politic and
support financial group who have
monopoly in Ukraine and that why the
economic in Ukraine doesn't have equal
opportunities how we break system
corrupt system we have its job just
couple of points very important points
we have to return Father to the corner
respectful very respectful law the
second point
papa dog walkers dance colossus peaceful
construction of civil society you could
kick the window control over to lado
there has to control the power and main
point what we need we need political
will to change that and we have good
examples in past time when political
leaders doesn't have political will and
we have good examples for example
country small country as Georgia have
made good steps and make good reforms
and fire is wind against corruption good
results in war against corruption its
main point if we can realize that we can
change our system and main point
what can't bring our country to modern
world is corruption thank you thank you
and if you have any questions please go
to the microphone and be in the back of
the room next question please
who are some of the political thinkers
and philosophers who have most
influenced your thinking and also who
are some of the political leaders past
and present who you most respect
I read very oft many many politicians
make very good influence in politic
Churchill cannot add an hour
Lingle it's many you know with many many
effects examples of the different it's
every politician have make a good
decision in in in right moment and every
politician is very interesting to read
the manners of a politician
they told we're right now it's not by
power and right now we can explain truth
what does mean and it's mean it's way by
power than explain they explain all
truth it's interesting to read many
different politicians I hope from for
the present time it's difficult to say
politic is just instrument to make it
changes in society and that way I go to
politic and that wise many young people
support us and also look not to be the
politician but we doesn't have it
another chance
we have great same you can you help me
suitable same artists political very
very popular in Ukraine
Sheeta cool same artist political cheap
political push Nazim artists to boil
either you engage in politics or
politics we'll start taking care of you
thank you for equation next question
please
I bow and ask the question in Ukrainian
in vanilla answer even I mean I've asked
it in English panel is called a pre
hello to to knows my crush when you
hesitate you theta Y approaches Cassata
show ya push our salad democratization
in the traveler could have enough
sneaker q premiere-minister
party booster on University - I mean
instance the cordon express boost
Princeton to America pressure to replace
no fuel initiative shots to thank you
zucchini cake inside necrosha diploma in
agile which nice aesthetic net
accomplishment in element
recite after Carol Dmitri of in
pollution pollution Oakland no peaceful
pomerantseva revoluta he have a hotel
condition easily yet biscotti signor
valley a hotel hang out the president
made very F should be no cha level
Russia direct investment fund okay the
reality is that when Paul would be
became a democratic country in the early
1990s the prime minister of Poland was a
graduate of this university the foreign
minister was a graduate of Princeton the
democratic forces have shown no interest
in any of this talent from Ukraine which
has come here there are 1700 students
here at any one time I'm sure there are
several PhDs and this in this auditorium
who could provide Goodling and language
skills why aren't the democratic forces
interested in any of this talent and
ignore it and I can provide many
specific examples of this Carol Demetria
returned to Ukraine after the Orange
Revolution and he's a Harvard MBA a
Stanford undergraduate worked for
McKinsey and he left Ukraine because the
democratic forces were not listening to
him okay and he's now he's now you know
he was hired by professor President
Medvedev to run the begin and run the
Russian you know direct investment fund
where are your experts and where are you
defining them
I'm sorry maybe the question is I know
video very well but I listen his death
take education in Harvard
oh he study here it's very very good
question thank you very much it's very
important too if you see the view to
Ukraine if you see how politician work
in Ukraine they promise so much clear
numbers more than 50% of population in
Ukraine don't believe any politician any
political party why because they promise
a lot they fighting for the power if
they come to the power they support the
interest of party they support the
interest of financial group they doesn't
support the interests of the people and
they was many times in in power they
changed there was many times the Prime
Minister they people who promised what
the president and don't keep his
promising don't change whole situation
in Ukraine don't keep his promising and
that why it's very important big
percentage of people not interesting in
politic any more on Ukraine
it's very passive and don't believe the
politician can change something for the
country can change something for people
and it's very important to change the
generation of politician
who have a chance many times to make
reform have many chance to keeping his
promising in realized in life what he
say but the species of Ukrainian
politician is perfect they say right
things but the distance between to say
and to doing it's pretty long and they
say but nobody nobody realized his
promise in his life and that way it's
great the way do it
Saakashvili I make an example Georgia as
one of the example many people with
whose young people who is good educated
he is not involved in corruption net
Network what was in in Georgia can
change a lot and main point I talk about
that today political will to change its
main point the four make reform in
country thank you thank you
I have two questions one is very short
what is your view on status of Ukrainian
language hey what's your second question
also second question you mentioned that
you mentioned that you want to do
electoral reform we know that since
independence in 1991 Ukraine has changed
electoral laws three times so it seems
like if we change it one more time and
you will do we will make an open spiral
list then there will be so many pirates
as we know they can never reach
consensus so what is the point of
changing the electoral law again the
question of language is very important
for Ukraine important and not the same
time in Ukraine more than 70
nationalities many people speaking
different languages many people have
made a different religion go to
different charge and yes of course if
you live in Ukraine if you politician if
you have
if you politician if you I'm sorry for
my English I try to find the right words
you have to talk in Ukrainian I'm
actually Russian Ukrainian who speak
Russian
I speak right now good you crane Ian but
I studied Ukrainian a bit later and in
lettuce years I begin to study 10 years
ago
Ukrainian many politician try to play
with this card is it different between
Ukrainian help of Ukraine speak Russian
half a Ukrainian speak rhenium they told
Ukrainian Ukraine for Ukrainian one
language religion equation we have to
concentrate our to concentrate attention
for question which united our country
and I told to everyone is not important
which language you speak it's not
important
which nationality you have it's not
important which religion I have is much
more important if you live in Ukraine
you like you love this country or not
second question
I understand you speak Ukrainian
my-my-my in Russia in Russia discuss
with me should be out by this Court
Whistler de cortes oh it's Boris Korea
reserved a post area which they ask what
you posterity
sure dijanna mova ukrainians in the
mayan exhuming of poking the booty Oh
crane scare my friends are prompting me
my friends are prompting me to voice the
Sailor the following position argument
that there is no doubt that the state
language in Ukraine has to be must be
Ukrainian election law
we built the Democrat Democrat
democratic country and but we play in
let you drove a pulley expert on foreign
foreign field on somebody in foreign
field because before election a local
election it's party of power allowed to
take a part of election just one month
before election they forbidden to take a
part of the nation young parties and
that way we have we show a great result
but we have just 1 months for
preparation it's very good base for
party of power right now in one year we
know it will be election we discuss
about election law but nobody nobody see
election law and that why is in this
situation we have to be prepared for
different scenario its main point for
what we have to prepare we meet the
people we explain our vision we explain
our value and we
explain many of Ukrainian have a chance
to seize different life standards
European live stars and more than half
of Ukrainian Ukrainian belief Ukraine
will be European country and our
direction in our European values and I'm
mother's row we European we are pian
with our country we European without
with our history we are build with our
with our mentality but we far away from
Europe from live standards in standards
of law and that way we have to change in
Ukraine a lot and also election law
right now we doesn't have a chance to
change that change that but we work
pretty hard and I hope I'll go to be
party of power and make changes in
Ukraine in Ukrainian politic and bring
Ukraine close to European value thank
you you've been talking about Europe a
lot that you like to join the European
Union do you have any you know fears
that have Ukraine does join the European
Union and if they do use the URL that it
might be dominated by Germany and France
and a lot of countries now the acronym
pigs Portugal Italy Ireland Greece and
Spain they're having a lot of problems
because you said there's European values
but the differences even between Greece
and Germany are just enormous and stuff
and used to talk that there are
different life standards in Ukraine and
Germany which most people think
dominates the EU do you worry that
Ukraine would be a very small player in
the new European Union if it was to join
European
as a question who will be dominate in
European Union and right now the Germany
and even a right understanding question
it's not about determination it's about
rules about standards about standards of
life and that why yes we have a problem
right now financial problems but all the
European Union Greek we have the same
standards send us the same standards in
law and European standards in law in
European Union and with the same
standards right now it's actually a
Greek part of European Union and main
point for Ukraine to have the same
standards of law Ukraine announced our
go European Union our direction our
vision our value is European but I
talked about that huge difference
between talk and do it and it's European
you your European value if we doesn't
have dialogue between the power and
opposition after demonstration I
explained a about demonstration small
and little business he support his rise
immediately next week the leaders of
demonstration
go to jail it's democratic Valley or not
exactly the same about Ukrainian
politics the leaders of a position one
and after that another one go to the
jail we doesn't have a discussion
between the power of the party of power
in opposition it's directly way to
attacker autocracy and we live pretty
long time in Soviet Union we know what
is what is mean dictator and we know
what is it freedom we want to build
democratic country and that why we today
it's painful to to read the numbers in
in newspaper when right now is some
countries European Union blocked
agreement of European Association of
Ukraine
it was first step to Europe why because
Ukrainian party of power break all rules
in whole world understand that whole
world
Critias I bet and if we want to be your
part of European Union first point we
have to understand European value and
leave exactly the same rules which live
whole Europe is equation who will be the
leader of European Union my opinion is
not the point where we have to
concentrate no questions
economically Germany and French leaders
but they biggest donors for another
country for another's members of
European Union and help for countries a
lot and yes of course European Union
very interesting to have Ukraine the
country second largest country in Europe
with stable economy with stable
political situation and worth of
European Union they were interested and
but right now everything depend of
Ukraine of Ukrainian citizen in just one
way legally to change all situation its
election in next year the politician has
to change in Ukraine that's why our
political party prepare for the nether
for election 2012 and we hope the
election in 2012 will be like most test
what news test for Ukrainian democracy
we need support for international
of national observance yes of course we
need the help for European Union from
American to control fear game in Ukraine
politic but everything depend of us and
one more point I want to talk about that
in Ukraine also in the United States
it's many people I call these people
armchair experts they sit in the home
front on TV the right article they
explain the opinion but from them depend
nothing we have five thousand ten
thousand millions of X this experts they
can't change nothing that why we go in
party that why we think we have a dream
and we do it
it's not easy game I know it's cost a
lot of energy time and it's huge stress
but we know we deliver himself and we
believe Ukraine have all chance to be
democratic country and we work we don't
want to wait and that why we are right
now in Baltic thank you very question
next question please very
thought-provoking speech
we have classes scheduled at one o'clock
so some of the students might have to
have to leave this is not voting with
their feet support no know that your
brain needs to accelerate its economic
growth and at the same time you
mentioned that economics and democracia
go hand by hand but however if the
Lutheran's who vote the strongest growth
doesn't go to Europe under democracy
it appears pretty much longer dictators
if you find says look on China all right
for instance under Pinochet children
from zero store heroes and we don't
actually observe examples of such a
first under democracies so globally it
doesn't look like democracy and
economics go hand by hand why do things
that in your brain they will go together
- endorsements to make recently
granado's who can creatively
it's much easier we'll be in Ukraine yet
sure that the most list of luteum
business ooh buddha wat a business to do
what if it knows name now more
concurrency original registry say pre me
put the rosette coup economies new rose
boutique Ukraine its every the casados
Italy does it mahoto pricklyleaf
historian if people who engage in
business are given the opportunity to do
business based on competitiveness and
equal conditions applicable to all
that's one of the most important
prerequisites of economic development
and the world experience has proven that
Alright Patania cation he the Marathi
pride cool maja warm oh well posthumous
sure students leadership in occupy
Atticus mission and sistema vonabell M
dollars lowest business witness we
didn't keep a resume if say action
Etowah ten most realistic on currency
action other what enlisted summation and
owatta the a curation luta me akiza
miles business um Tony maws legal repeat
the economy scenario for my vulnerable
economic narrow for me pollution
during upon the result are a key we're
worried live as far as the as the case
of China is concerned what they have is
okay we know the situation with human
rights there and democracy but what they
have is a kind of a mixed system when
the Chinese authorities gave us
themselves a clear account of the
importance of given their businesses
equal opportunities and creating for
them competitive environment within
which they could develop and also the
importance of vieira fulfilling economic
reforms as a condition for such a rapid
economic development
yes numerical part elusive khatai chief
shaking Oh mr. kuhmo sivanna card show
Perriman a duty our mini boot alley
naturally and attacks with Kuya Connie
Morella Basu I have many Chinese friends
and I speak with them quite often and
they say that the changes actually take
place but they're not as quick as they
would wish them to be keep a nice
awareness Nadine Trotsky engine is
khatai classic rock is Tomo the channel
of today is somewhat different from the
China of 20 years ago
sumo but there was a coup business
morale to demokratische neck to
democracy to rattle a con la mesa verde
dame of envelope island sweetie
yo crema the shitty bit in there is
rough oak relative over bailamos latinos
who initiated in the mostly was there
authorities
created all conditions necessary for the
development of business however what we
have in China is very far from democracy
on the other hand China exists in a
global world and cannot be permanently
isolated
from what's going on in the world the
Yakuza ppattani
firmly sure vote Patania sheer jostle
thank you for your question and I think
that it's also a question of time as far
as China is concerned Yuri Shevchuk has
done a great job at translating and so I
think it's only fair that he should be
allowed to ask a question as well thank
you so much
I will ask my question first in in
English and if our guest mic I teach
Ukrainian language here I have taught
here for seven years and of course the
language issue is something that I am
both professionally and emotionally
invested and my question is it's all
wonderful and that you support the
status the state status of for Ukrainian
language however the situation in
Ukraine is such that if a person you
know with all goodwill would like to
learn Ukrainian and I compliment you on
learning Ukrainian it's a huge challenge
to do that because unlike for instance
in Canada or the United States there is
no such a thing is in Ukraine as free of
charge language courses in which you can
enroll and just go in the evening and
have a highly qualified instructor of
language who will teach you the language
that is supposed to unite that
multi-million nation into one not be the
cause for division but really for for
unification of that and the language
issue has been all the time exploited by
politicians and I must say very
effectively to divide the nation do you
have a kind of a tangible concrete
program to implement the
absolutely wonderful principle of
supporting Ukrainian as state language
and why why I am at it I would like to
to give you a little present from our
program because we invited you here at
the Ukrainian Studies program we just we
just published this book for of
Ukrainian language for beginners I would
like to take it with you to Ukraine and
as a kind of as a kind of a sign that
Ukrainian can be not only supported
declaratively but in deeds and use this
perhaps not you yourself have already
you have already conquered it that
probably just show it around and thank
you to give you an answer for your
question is just a simple point how we
bring people to learn Ukrainian and to
speak Ukrainian language the government
from the past tried to push the people
to learn language it's wrong way has to
be modern to speak Ukrainian it's have
to be cool to speak Ukrainian especially
for young generation is will be
automatically and people in the in the
identified didn't identify himself and
if they want to be and it will be modern
it will be automatically it's not the
situation right now many politician in
Ukraine plays language Croatian as
political card here we for the language
where somebody who doesn't speak
Ukrainians not Ukraine anymore and they
play to the game this will be much easy
to make modern this is language to show
a good example it's much more effective
effective for
or make a language Ukrainian language
Ukraine must modern language yeah
fashionable yeah thank you thank you
thank you next question please in
preparation for today's meeting I read
carefully at the program of your
political party and I was very
pleasantly surprised with a very big and
rather elaborated chapter on ensuring
gender equality with a very profound
understanding of the issue I would very
confidently say that your party is
probably the only one in Ukraine to make
such strong claims and to offer such a
radical action plan for gender equality
and this is what the gender rights
advocates would only dream about and
would you excuse me for saying the
following it sounds too good to be true
and my suspicion has a reason I come
from l'viv and in leave the live branch
of your party recently introduced at the
local agenda for the city development it
contains a ten position and there is no
mention of gender issues whatsoever in
that plan so it looks like there is a
slight gap between the big declaration
and the practical implementation of
those declared principles so my question
is how serious are you and your party
about gender equality and what are your
real commitment to implement the
principles of gender equality in
Ukrainian society or it is perhaps just
the very instrumental use of gender
issues to improve the international
image of your party to be the most
advanced
ever thank you
I smile because I came to the United
States not alone together with my
friends and I have here in what about
gender politic is my friends he's so
huge experts in this question and I just
touched the question in in my speech I'm
more than sure we have to involve more
and more women's to politics and 30% of
I present 30% in City Council in in Kiev
the members of our party is women's I
wish more women's not because I like so
much women's I like now it's also the
reason because because you know about
what I talk it's Ukrainian woman's have
some special mean doubt he says some
special quality they do and they take
responsibility for work much more harder
than man's and I'm sorry for that is
real and
and generally politic in its we have
peak platform and many points in our
program sister Suzie will be stupid
Laska I am sorry it's pretty long time
doesn't have practice in English and
that's why I try to find Wars shoes to
suit the general in a politically you
just do notice though us the most those
pneumatic speech to Planitia Bousema
pump Tamiya Kunis Masha program here in
p3 my whatsapp is my emotion so to
reverse Ludo Patania support Anya
National Party a politician apart name
never knows it Aleph su just know
sweetie
Sepp Italians need to the host rock we
we are fully aware of the great
importance of gender politics and we are
probably the only party in Ukraine that
gives such such importance to this to
this issue and you can get of
familiarize yourself with that in our
program thank you very much
next question please can you hear me
thank you for coming out good to see you
hope you come more often
Ukrainian Democratic Alliance for reform
the dark party it's a new party has
found that last year right April
first I want to say good luck with the
party I hope you make progress I need
fresh blood and there's there's a lot of
people who need to get washed out of
there and the question is from personal
experience regarding entering the
politics world over there do you feel as
threatened at all do you feel what
negative experiences have you had there
and do you see improvement from midnight
news that's one part of the question
second part of the question is what
concrete steps do you plan on taking to
to keep expanding your support support
base
can you can you repeat the second part I
didn't hear you approach it with the
passes she certainly moved as a pastime
of political which is a story Catherine
bolivianos devotee prahlada if the row
across the kisser here upon your
approach of provenance the Dodgers who
also publicly pass the pepper Channel
I want to tell you
Ukrainian politic is something special
if we talk about politic general and
Ukrainian politics is we build wield
wild capitalism and Ukrainian politics I
am boxer but in Ukrainian politics
I feel me like in fight without rules
and if you ask me about the dangerous
yeah it's it's dangerous life not
democratic countries cause it's cost
nothing and the main point in every
democratic countries modern countries
it's human freedom in Ukraine main value
not the human Naza freedom
is it money and we want to change this
situation
what about dangerous it's yes the risk
there and we're but main point give to
us so much power we defend the interests
of the people the right of the people
and that why we write that why we fight
not for our party not for us we we fight
for the interest of country the interest
of population and what about the risk
or risks we don't think about that we
just do it and I've no no threats no
negative experiences so far yeah we
negative experience
I know it's politic is duty game before
I came to party
I came to politic with six six years ago
with Roz Rosen glasses and glasses fall
down and very very fast and I know it's
do the game but I don't think it's so
duty I have a negative experience I read
about me and my family so many things
but sayings dancing special happens and
I hope it's not happiness in the future
okay thank you thank you thank you very
much I think that we should wrap up
because you would like to meet with some
of the members of the audience and
perhaps signed a few flyers and things
if we could so with that I'd like to I'm
sorry that we don't have time for more
questions I'm not sure if you think that
the boxing ring or the the open
auditorium there's a more is a more
dangerous place given that the questions
nobody pulled any punches with their
questions which is we always like to see
I would just like to thank everybody for
coming and if we could have a big round
of applause for our speaker
the time for one more quick question and
then we'll ask people to come up and we
would ski yes sir - ahah ah-choo animal
academia new decent McCallum you know GU
ke the Isuzu GU clean measured watch a
choo-choo that director Institute to
Europe Asia is decision Academy no crane
alenushka passes the person she up
shopping with Bowie Albany president I'm
sorry Mia so miserable yes American
corruption Yakka Pam you enjoy clean I
remember IIIi have been 20 years a
member of Ukrainian Academy of Sciences
I have two questions the first question
is what would you do in case you became
president or prime minister of ukraine
with rampant corruption
Julia trains is political before a
Jewish my body so short of a she also
mystery respect although you are a man
with huge and powerful fists but a lot
of Ukrainian politicians already are in
a better world that aren't you aren't
you sometimes afraid for your life when
you engage in politics so you can for
equation is very interesting question if
if we have a chance to change and which
priority have Ukraine which party is
steps we can do it I want to tell its
main points just four points main value
in Ukraine have to be human not the
money
second second one to the column
respectful law without that we can build
our society the muslim winnie pooh
poohed avati budova cruz dance drama
goes pizza we must construct civil
society a parvati economical policy and
build the economy on equal opportunities
say osmanli punk t a keeper women with
repetitive dilemma smugly rucap is to
democratize most peaceful path C Ponte
President Assad see marshal seesi injury
for - moment in the boot martin echo
effect these are the principal things we
need to do in order to be able to move
on further to democratic society what
about my i feel me secure and sometimes
i with opening appointment with
thousands of people i use security and
the guys who care about not me it's some
so many people it's no no pressure and
sometimes the small children comment to
to make atta gram and one of journalists
ask of security guy oh you care about
Klitschko and security mental you know
what to be honest he can care about me
thank you for your question and it's
very interesting question is one short
speech I explained about this example
very often I want to explain you some
story 1986 Ukraine Kiev group of boys
after school go to some apartment and
show sport event in Soviet Union was
forbidden to see professional boxing but
perestroika time and we have a chance to
see the professional fights professional
boxing fights in this fight youngest
heavyweight champion youngest
heavyweight take one's world title and I
was so impressed I just was beginner in
boxer in boxing I was impressed from the
fight the guy hold the title above the
hand it was Mike Tyson I was impressed I
tell to my friends who sit together with
me in one thing I will be I want to be
world champion I pizza guy and takes a
belt away my friends look at me
I was so skinny looking muscle machine
Tyson and starting to kidding me and
making jokes they don't know I have good
memory I memorized everyone who make a
jokes about me sixth year letter I
invite everyone with who we sit together
and sissified brings back with me take
from the bag the belt exactly the same
belt what holding Mike Tyson above the
head who to the table had asked
guys I remember the day when you make a
jokes about me we saw the disulphide
everybody tell ya we remember that and
then and I asked and now yeah we don't
know it's some boy from our class from
our school can be world champ a
heavyweight champion of the world
why explains the story it's very
important I see so many young people
here it's very important is life to have
a dream it's not just the dream to have
important important doing work very hard
to make a dream true and nothing is
impossible any dream what you have you
can realize I'll reach my goal sport I
have a dream Ukraine will be modern
European country and we can do it that
if you have a goal and somebody don't
believe in you make it jokes and smile
let's work don't think about that and
you need a time we need the time and
mother sure it's not just my dream a
dream of many thousands of millions of
people and we unite all people who
support our politic political movement
who support our party and who split and
change with our with us our vision and
we know our dream we make true Ukraine
will be European country not just
geographically not mentality or
historically we will be with all
European countries European with
European standards of life and
I hope in a couple of years who will
meet together here and I can explain how
difficult was to do that but we did
thank you